في معامل شركه بوينج في مدينه تشيلسون في
ولايه سادكارولاينا تتعمق الشراكه
الاقتصاديه والتجاريه بين الشركات
الامريكيه والمملكه العربيه السعوديه
الاستثمارات السعوديه في مستقبل المملكه
يتضح هنا في مراسيم هذا الحفل الذي يطلق
رسميا شراء السعوديه لاسطول من احدث ما
تنتجه شركه بوينج للطيران التجاري وهي
دريم لاينر لتاسيس شركه خطوط الرياض ضمن
رؤيه الامير محمد بن سلمان لتنويع
الاقتصاد وعدم الاتكال على النفط ولجعل
الرياض محطه اساسيه تجذب الزوار ورجال
الاعمال وتربط الشرق بالغرب
كشركه الناشئه ربما نكون اكبر شركه ناشئه
في التاريخ الحديث لذلك هذا هو وقت مثير
للطيران التجاري على نطاق عالمي وكذلك
للمملكه العربيه السعوديه لاننا في موضوع
الطيران نبدا بلا ارث بحيث ليست لدينا
انظمه قادمه الطراز وبهذا لدينا الفرصه
الان للتاكد من اننا اول شركه طيران
الرقميه حقيقيه في العالم
وهذه الشراكه تعكس بعد التعاون الحكومي
حيث تخلق فرص عمل لمليون امريكي امر اشاد
بها الرئيس بايدن وتحدث عنها السنه
ممثلا عن الولايه
التغيير حقيقي رؤيه ولي العهد هي لفتح
المملكه العربيه السعوديه للاستثمار
التجاري والسياحه باعلى جوده وتقنيه في
تاريخ البشريه للوصول الى ابرز الاماكن
السياحيه العالميه طبعا لا ينجح الامر الا
اذا قمت بتحديث وتطوير بلدك مع اجراء عده
تغييرات الان المراه يمكنها القياده
التعلم الذهاب الى المدرسه
سفيره المملكه الاميره ريما بن بندر ال
سعود وفي كلمتها رات ان الطيران هو اداه
دبلوماسيه لتقريب الشعوب وفهم الثقافات
ودعت كل من يرغب من الحضور الى زياره
المملكه بينما اكد الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه
الخطوط السعوديه الكابتن ابراهيم الكشي
على ان الرياض ستكون قبله جديده ستنافس
شركات طيران معروفه
من المتوقع ان تنمو المملكه العربيه
السعوديه بشكل اسرع من اي منطقه اخرى في
العالم في تلك المنطقه لذلك لدينا عرض ذو
قيمه كبيره في موضوع السفر والسفر المحلي
في العالم العربي والسفر والسياحه الدينيه
لذلك لا نشعر ان المنافسه في هذا المجال
سيء بل هي تنمو للجميع
وسيصل اخر فوج من الطائرات بحلول عام 2025
اما التكلفه فواصلت الى 36 مليار دولار
اذا طيران الرياض الجديد والخطوط السعوديه
ستكون بمثابه الاجنحه التي ستحمل ما يقرب
من مئه مليون سائح سنويا الى المملكه
وستربط حوالي 250 مدينه بالرياض ضمن رؤيه
الاميره 2030 البدايه والنهايه هي هنا في
مصانع بوينت نادي البيبيسي تشيلسي في
ولايه ساسكو رولا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات